I am back partnering with Google to
share some of the new ways to search on
the Google App let's use my main man
Maddie as an example okay you ready do
you want to give Mommy a kiss
no I simply opened up the Google app I
tap the icon in the top left corner and
I toggle the feature on now from here I
can ask anything I want like how to
groom a pushon I am able to see an AI
powered snapshot that gives me the best
info and more for grooming my pup if I
want to take my search one step further
I can ask follow-up questions to learn
even more do you like that Maddie do you
want to get groomed a bath
he hates them I'm sorry no you don't
need one right now you smell nice for
more on how to enable this within the
Google app check out my video with them
from last week